kevin when your wife was here a couple
weeks ago we asked her a few questions
about you and your relationship
and if it's okay we want to ask you some
of those same
questions and just see if any of the
answers match up
okay i'll give it a shot all right kevin
bacon
this is your wife
[Applause]
[Music]
so what fun is a game you know without a
little steak so keira
says that um she's gonna tell you what
you are
playing for let's take a look okay
so kev if you get four out of five right
i will clean the dinner dishes for the
next year
but if you get them wrong you have to
clean the dinner dishes for the next
year
wow that's i don't know a year
wow okay okay
are you ready i'm ready your family has
matching tattoos if you got a tattoo
right now
what would it be uh princess kikanoki
here's what kira said if kevin got a
tattoo right now i think
it might say six degrees
for his um sixdegrees.org
not for the reason everyone will think
it will be but for the sixdegrees.org
oh uh-oh look i'm gonna be doing some
dishes
okay what is something of yours
that kira would just love for you to get
rid of
something i would love to get rid of
maybe uh an old pair of sneakers
oh here's what she said
the thing i would like kevin to get rid
of
is some of his t-shirts i'm a big fan of
him
in collard shirts yeah she made me put
on a collared shirt today
yeah cute um okay what's one thing of
keira's that
you would love to throw out
oh i would say uh all of her earrings
i haven't i have an earring phobia i
really don't like earrings
well here's what kira said i know i'm
gonna be right about this one the things
of mine that kevin would like me to get
rid of are
all my earrings not a fan of earrings
okay if you could eat one meal for the
rest of your life what would it be
a pizza uh-huh
okay here's what kira said if kevin had
to eat
one meal for the rest of his life i
think it would be something
like uh fish taco
[Applause]
he's actually right she knows you better
than you know yourself right
better than i know myself okay last
question which goat is your favorite
goat
well i hate to play favorites but macon
is
making bacon is pretty irresistible
here's what she said
kevin's favorite goat is macon shh
don't tell louie
we might keep be getting dirty with
those dishes later and i thank you so
much kevin bacon for coming on the show
today really thank you
thanks for having me groove i'm a big
fan and it's it's fantastic what you're
doing
and keep up the great work well thank
you
um city on a hill airs sundays on show
time at 9 00 pm eastern and pacific
say hi to kyra for me we'll do